[Applaudissements]
le président gordon des chemins de fer
du canadien national avait déclaré que
trop peu de canadiens français avait
assez de compétences pour devenir des
cadres supérieurs
sa déclaration mis en colère la
population francophone qui depuis des
siècles
voyez les meilleurs postes toujours
confiée à des anglais extrait d'un
documentaire de l'eau nf sur la crise
d'octobre les événements d'octobre 70
il n'ya plus d'écart réelle entre les
salaires des francophones et des
anglophones à toute fin pratique
aujourd'hui qu'en est il de la propriété
des entreprises le fameux québec inc
quotidien où en sommes nous en référons
nous à l'extrait du début aujourd'hui
celui qui dirige le cn c'est un
québécois jean jacques ruest comme quoi
les temps ont changé remontons à la
commission laurendeau dunton avec son
rapport qui est paru en 1967 et qui
disait dans le québec où il y a quatre
fois plus de francophones que
d'anglophones le nombre relatif des
propriétaires francophone est très
faible et que s'ils prédomine dans la
petite industrie
ils sont presque absents des secteurs
exigeant de forts investissements et une
technique avancée aujourd'hui dans le
top 10 des entreprises québécoises en
eh bien on retrouvait métro le mouvement
desjardins hydro québec la banque
nationale et bombardier toutes deux
propriétés québécoises est dirigé par
des francophones et le québec compte
maintenant parmi ces milliardaires à un
bouchard et jacques d'amours de couche
tard le pharmacien jean coutu serge
godet de la multinationale cj pierre
karl péladeau de québecor tous
francophones alors si dans les années 60
le contrôle de l'économie par les
francophones est inférieure à 50%
aujourd'hui ce serait estimé à aux deux
tiers environ par le cyrano le reste
étant qu'à paris par des propriétaires
anglo canadien ou encore étranger le
statut économique des francophones
nature quand même donc connu une
ascension important depuis 1966 -
observe qu'il plafonne depuis une
vingtaine d'années qu'en est il pour les
entreprises mais disons que la situation
est assez semblable la mondialisation
l'économie de marché la concurrence ça
ne facilite pas les choses
on l'a vu je vous donne des noms
bombardier et ronald effritement des
sièges sociaux au québec ça préoccupe
plus hauts sommets mais le québec inc
croit qu'il est possible du moins de
maintenir le statu quo en misant sur le
québec français en misant sur
l'innovation
voici louis vachon de la banque
nationale une institution financière
fondée au 19ème siècle par des
francophones
c'est sûr que la communauté anglophone
est encore présente la communauté
allophones étant un croissance bien sûr
mais les francophones ont bel et bien
pris leur place c'est sûr que la
définition de maîtres chez-nous évoluent
et changent avec un monde qui est plus
globalisé et un monde qui est plus
numérisé aussi le célèbre montréalais
anglophone mitch garber l'entrepreneur
et bien nous partager que quand il était
enfant
les commerces qui le voyait ses tests en
burg simpson
aujourd'hui ces couches tard c'est métro
alors selon lui aujourd'hui bien
l'argent est dans les mains des
francophones dans les mains des
québécois francophones on écoute le jour
où on sait par pas anglophone
francophone qui a plus d'argent
ça serait le meilleur journée dans
l'histoire du québec et je comprends
pourquoi on le fait aujourd'hui parce
que on a mal commencé
confolens mal parti dans les 70 70 dans
la culture francophone québécoise il y
avait il ya encore une réticence de
parler du succès financière des autres
et ça je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
erreur parce que on a tellement de deux
francophones succès ce qui serait donc
fondamental celui ce serait de valoriser
dans le réseau de l'éducation le succès
du monde des affaires
très intéressant merci mathieu pour ces
deux reportages hier et ce soir avant